Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Whether it's a family member, friend, or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muskoka or down Toronto's bustling streets.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要每周获取独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先看权限，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。无论是家庭成员、朋友还是毛茸茸的同伴加入你的夏季公路旅行，享受沃尔沃传奇安全性能带来的安心感。在沃尔沃发现日期间，在您计划畅游穆斯科卡或穿梭于多伦多繁华街道时，享受限时优惠。
From now until June 30th, lease a 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000. Conditions apply. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer or go to volvocars.ca for full details. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] All over the field, Roman soldiers lay dead in their thousands. Horse and foot mingled, as the shifting phases of the battle or the attempt to escape had brought them together.
即日起至6月30日，租赁2025款沃尔沃XC60，利率低至1.74%，最高可省4,000加元。须受条款约束。请访问您身边的GTA沃尔沃零售商或登录volvocars.ca了解完整详情。[《星条旗永不落》] 放眼望去，战场上横尸遍野，罗马士兵的尸体达数千具。由于战局的瞬息万变或绝望中的逃生尝试，骑兵和步兵的尸体交织混杂在一起。
Here and there wounded men covered with blood who had been roused to consciousness by the morning cold were dispatched by a quick blow as they struggled to rise from amongst the corpses. Others were found still alive with the sinews in their thighs and behind their knees sliced through, baring their throats and necks, and begging who would to spill what little blood they had left. Some had their heads buried in the ground, having apparently dug themselves holes, and by smothering their faces with earth, had choked themselves to death. Most strange of all was a Numidian soldier
有些满身鲜血的伤员被清晨的寒意唤醒，在挣扎着从尸堆中起身时，被快速的一击了结了性命。另一些人则被发现尚有一息存留，他们大腿和膝盖后方的肌腱被割断，咽喉与颈部裸露在外，苦苦哀求任何人来放尽他们体内仅存的一点血。还有些人将头埋进土里，显然是自己挖了洞，通过用泥土堵住面部，窒息而亡。最离奇的是一名努米底亚士兵，
still living and lying with nose and ears horribly lacerated underneath the body of a Roman who when his useless hands had no longer been able to grasp his sword had died in the act of tearing his enemy in bestial fury with his teeth. So that was the account of the act of tearing his enemy in bestial fury with his teeth. So that was the account of the battlefield of Cannae by Livy and he's describing the morning after one of the bloodiest and most notorious days in the entire history, not just of Rome or of the Punic Wars but of armed conflict generally because this is one of the most studied, most discussed, most famous battles in all world history. It took place on the 2nd of August 216 BC.
他依然活着，躺在一名罗马士兵的尸体下，鼻子和耳朵被恐怖地撕裂。当他那双无用的双手再也无法握住宝剑时，他竟然在野兽般的狂怒中用牙齿撕咬敌人而死。这就是李维对坎尼战场的记载，他所描述的是历史上最血腥、最恶名昭彰的日子之一的次日清晨。这不仅是罗马或布匿战争史上的至暗时刻，更是整个武装冲突史上的至暗时刻，因为这是世界历史上被研究最多、讨论最多、最著名的战役之一。它发生于公元前216年8月2日。
And Tom, for the Romans, this was the darkest day in all their history, wasn't it? It was. And for as long as their empire endured, Roman historians who wanted to emphasize some particular shattering defeat would say, oh, this was the worst day ever except for Cannae. And they would always acknowledge that even the worst defeat wasn't as terrible as Cannae had been. And I think what is fascinating is that modern historians as well have been kind of equally fascinated by the scale of the slaughter that was inflicted on Rome on that terrible day. So there are two really excellent studies of this battle, one by Greg Daly, Cannae, the experience of battle in the Second Punic War.
汤姆，对罗马人来说，这是他们历史上最黑暗的一天，对吧？确实如此。在他们的帝国延续的漫长岁月中，任何想要强调某次粉碎性惨败的罗马史学家都会说：“哦，这是有史以来最糟糕的一天，除了坎尼。”他们总是承认，哪怕是最惨重的失败也比不上坎尼那般可怕。我认为令人着迷的是，现代历史学家同样对那场可怕灾难中罗马人被屠杀的规模着迷不已。关于这场战役有两部非常优秀的研究著作，其中一部是格雷格·戴利（Greg Daly）的《坎尼：第二次布匿战争中的战斗体验》。
He writes, very striking fact that there were more Romans and Italians killed in one day of fighting at Cannae than Americans killed in combat during the whole Vietnam War. Wow. Yeah, that's a good fact. I mean, that's an amazing stat. And then Adrian Goldsworthy, who is essentially what my brother is to the Second World War, he is to the Roman army. I mean, he is the goat on this. And he wrote an excellent book on Cannae as well. And it has an introduction from Richard Holmes, you know, the great military historian and Richard Holmes writes the Romans lost more men killed than the British army on the first day of the Somme in 1916, which I guess for British
他写道，一个非常惊人的事实是，在坎尼战役中一天之内阵亡的罗马人和意大利人，比美国在整个越南战争中战斗阵亡的人数还要多。哇。是的，这确实是个很有力的事实。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的统计数据。然后是阿德里安·戈兹沃西（Adrian Goldsworthy），他在罗马军队领域的地位，就相当于我弟弟在第二次世界大战领域的地位。我的意思是，他就是这个领域的GOAT（历史最佳）。而且他也写了一本关于坎尼的优秀著作。这本书有理查德·霍姆斯（Richard Holmes，你知道的那位伟大的军事历史学家）写的序言，理查德·霍姆斯写道，罗马人阵亡的士兵人数超过了英国军队在1916年索姆河战役第一天的阵亡人数，我想这对于英国
people is always the kind of, it's the measuring stick of pointless slaughter. Isn't it? But of course those are Vietnam and the first world war, both industrialized conflicts. So the idea that a battle in the ancient world could have a scale of slaughter to rank alongside the conflicts of the modern age just seems extraordinary. But it's not the only reason why Cannae is such a famous battle, is it? It's also famous because, you know, for people who are great students of military tactics,
人来说，一直以来都是衡量无意义屠杀的标尺，不是吗？但当然，越南战争和第一次世界大战都是工业化冲突。因此，古代世界的一场战役，其屠杀规模竟然能与现代社会的冲突相提并论，这听起来似乎非同寻常。但这并不是坎尼之所以成为如此著名的战役的唯一原因，对吧？它之所以出名，还因为对于那些精通军事战术的人来说，
this is like sort of Maradona's second goal against England in 1986 or one of Lionel Messi's great performances in Roger Federer or something. It is the acme of perfection. Yeah, exactly. It is the absolute archetype of a vastly outnumbered force annihilating a much superior one. And it's for that reason, I think, as Greg Daly puts it in his book, that can I may be the most studied battle in history, because obviously if you can distill the elixir, work out the formula that Hannibal applied, then hopefully you can apply that to your own age and win similarly stunning victories. And I mean, you'll know this Dominic as a student historian of the First World War, that First World War generals and strategists were obsessed by Cannae. So Schlieffen is the kind of the
这就像是马拉多纳在1986年对阵英格兰时的第二个进球，或是莱昂内尔·梅西的伟大表现之一，又或是罗杰·费德勒的经典之作。它是完美的巅峰。是的，完全如此。这绝对是兵力处于巨大劣势的一方全歼优势之敌的绝对原型。正因如此，正如格雷格·戴利在他的书中所说，坎尼很可能是历史上被研究最多的战役，因为很显然，如果你能提炼出其中的精髓，找出汉尼拔运用的公式，那么希望你就能把它应用到你自己的时代，赢得同样惊人的胜利。而且我的意思是你一定知道这一点，多米尼克，作为一名研究一战的学生历史学家，一战的将军和战略家们对坎尼简直着迷。所以施利芬就是那种
famous example that he was the chief of the German general staff wasn't he? In kind of before the First World War devised this the Schlieffen plan or did he? I mean, I know it's very controversial, but essentially the German high command were aiming at a battle of annihilation that was consciously inspired by what Hannibal had done. And after the war, there was a collection of his essays published that just had the title Can I? And then in the Second World War, on the Eastern front, again, lots of Hitler's generals were obsessed with replicating Hannibal's tactics. So Guderian in particular, you know, with his tanks, warring across the Eastern
著名的例子，他是德国总参谋长，对吧？在一战前夕制定了所谓的“施利芬计划”，或者说真的是他吗？我的意思是，我知道这很有争议，但基本上德国最高统帅部旨在进行一场有意识地受到汉尼拔事迹启发歼灭战。战后，出版过一本他的文集，书名就叫《坎尼》。然后在二战的东线战场上，希特勒的许多将军同样痴迷于复制汉尼拔的战术。特别是古德里安，你知道的，他带着坦克在东线
Front. He was very inspired by the example of the Carthaginian cavalry at Cannae. And weirdly, Americans with German names were also obsessed. So Eisenhower was obsessed by it. And more recently recently Norman Schwarzkopf who commanded the American forces in Desert Storm. He was always going on about how his tactics and strategy there were modeled on Hannibal. It's the kind of thing that I imagine that if I was to study at West Point, a man in a bow tie would talk about this battle for weeks. Firstly talk about Thucydides.
横冲直撞。他深受坎尼战役中迦太基骑兵事迹的启发。奇怪的是，那些拥有德国姓氏的美国人也同样着迷。艾森豪威尔就对它着迷。更近一些时候，指挥沙漠风暴美军的诺曼·施瓦茨科夫也是如此。他总是津津乐道于他在那里的战术和战略是如何以汉尼拔为原型的。这让我想象，如果我在西点军校学习，一个戴蝴蝶结的男人会连续几周谈论这场战役。首先谈论修昔底德。
And then they'd have you as a guest lecturer or something, Tom. It'd be awful. It'd be soul destroying. Oh, what, for the listeners or for me? No, I mean, you'd be handsomely remunerated. But I, as the student, I'd first have to endure the lecture by the man in the bow tie and then you'd pitching up to give an hour long lecture and my life would be in ruins. Anyway, let's move on.
然后他们会请你作为客座讲师什么的，汤姆。那可太糟了。那会摧毁心灵。哦，什么，对听众还是对我？不，我的意思是，你会获得丰厚的报酬。但我作为学生，首先得忍受戴蝴蝶结的男人的讲座，然后你又登台进行长达一小时的演讲，我的生活就要彻底毁了。无论如何，我们继续往下讲。
This is an amazing subject because the thing is that there is a risk with viewing Can I as a kind of platonic ideal of a battle, because if you abstract it, you get away from what actually makes the study of this battle of maybe all the battles in ancient history so compelling and so unsettling and actually terrifying. Because what both Daly and Goldsworthy do in their two actually quite different books, but in one thing they're very similar, they really emphasize the physicality of warfare generally, but specifically in this battle. And it reminds us that Cannae is a battle that is fought in the context of the much broader war that we've been talking about in this series between distinctive commanders, between distinctive armies, cities, ways of life. And the ancient sources, and you quoted Livy, but we have Polybius as well, we have Plutarch. visceral in their accounts of what actually happens when the Roman and the Carthaginian
这是一个令人惊叹的主题，因为问题在于，将坎尼视为战役的柏拉图式理想存在着一种风险，因为如果你将其抽象化，你就会脱离使这场战役——或许也是古代历史中所有战役——的研究如此引人入胜、令人不安甚至真正恐怖的本质。因为戴利和戈兹沃西在他们两本其实截然不同但有一点非常相似的书中所做的，就是他们真正强调了战争普遍的实体感，尤其是这场战役中的实体感。它提醒我们，坎尼这场战役是发生在我们在这系列节目中一直讨论的更广泛的战争背景之中的，这是一场不同指挥官之间、不同军队、城市、生活方式之间的战争。古代文献——你引用了李维，但我们还有波利比乌斯，还有普鲁塔克——
way of war comes up against each other in this great titanic clash, and they evoke the dust, the stench, the terror, the horror, which even the victors on the day after the battle are kind of struck dumb by it. And I think that it's possible to evoke and make vivid in a way that is not true about other battles in antiquity, something of the lived experience of those who fought in it. So that's why it's so interesting. So we can immerse ourselves in a way that we can't with other battles. We can immerse ourselves in what it was like to be there. So before we get into the sort of the total immersion as it were,
在描述当罗马与迦太基的战争方式在这一伟大泰坦式的冲突中正面碰撞时实际发生了什么时，他们的描绘是如此身临其境、血淋淋的。他们唤起了尘土、恶臭、恐惧、惊骇，以至于战役结束后的第二天连胜利者都被震撼得哑口无言。我认为，以一种古代其他战役所不具备的方式，去唤醒并生动展现那些参战者的亲身经历是可能的。这就是它如此有趣的原因。因此，我们可以以一种研究其他战役时无法做到的方式让自己沉浸其中。我们可以让自己沉浸在身临其境的感受中。所以在我们进入这种完全沉浸式的体验之前，
let's give ourselves a little bit of context. So Hannibal, listeners will remember, had invaded Italy in autumn 218, this amazing journey across the Alps with his elephants that took two weeks, then down into the Valley of the Po, he had defeated a combined Roman army at the river Trebia. a combined Roman army at the river Trebia. Then six months or so later, the summer of 217, he had ambushed an entire Roman army near Lake Trasimene. That's seen in the defile when all his men are up on the heights and they come pouring down. And they'd killed the consul who was commanding the Pete Hegseth of the Roman Republic, if you remember. He's been roaming around southern Italy, around Campania, the Roman breadbasket, torching the estates of the Roman nobility.
让我们先了解一些背景。听众们会记得，汉尼拔于公元前218年秋天入侵意大利，他带着大象翻越阿尔卑斯山的这段惊人旅程花了两个星期，然后进入波河流域，并在特雷比亚河击败了一支联合罗马军队。在特雷比亚河击败了一支联合罗马军队。大约六个月后，即公元前217年夏天，他在特拉西梅诺湖附近伏击了一整支罗马军队。那是发生在一个峡谷里的伏击，当时他所有的士兵都在高处，然后倾巢而出。他们杀死了统帅，也就是罗马共和国的皮特·海格塞斯（Pete Hegseth），如果你还记得的话。此后他一直在意大利南部游荡，在罗马粮仓坎帕尼亚一带，烧毁罗马贵族的庄园。
Since then he has been on the eastern flank of Rome in Apulia. It's basically R&R for his men. They've been recharging their batteries, haven't they? So at this point, Tom, what does Hannibal want to do? What's his plan to take the city of Rome to destroy the Roman Republic? No, that's too ambitious for him. So what does he think he's going to plausibly do? I think that the Romans assume that his ambition is to wipe out Rome, but I think that they're
从那以后，他一直在罗马东翼的普利亚。这基本上是他部下的休假疗养。他们一直在充电蓄力，不是吗？所以在这一点上，汤姆，汉尼拔想做什么？他攻占罗马城、摧毁罗马共和国的计划是什么？不，这对他来说太野心勃勃了。那么他认为自己实际上能 plausibly（合理地）做到什么？我认为罗马人假设他的野心是消极地抹去罗马，但我认为他们是将自己的假设投射到了汉尼拔身上。我不认为汉尼拔——嗯，我们从后来他与马其顿国王签订条约时就能知道这一点，他在条约中明确了罗马在其中的角色。他并没有说罗马将被彻底抹去。他本质上想要的是摧毁意大利境内支撑罗马权力的同盟体系，这个体系之所以能支撑罗马，是因为它为罗马提供了兵源。贯穿整个系列节目我们一直在讨论，这是罗马权力的关键，汉尼拔意识到了这一点，他的战略是试图削弱罗马的声望。他主要想通过
projecting their own assumptions onto Hannibal there. I don't think Hannibal, well we know this because later he signs treaties say with the King of Macedon and he specifies what Rome's role will be in this. He's not saying that Rome is going to be wiped out. What he wants essentially is to destroy the alliance system in Italy that upholds Roman power and it upholds it because it provides Rome with men. The whole way through the series we've been talking, this is the key to Roman power and Hannibal recognizes that and his strategy is to try and kneecap Rome's prestige and he wants to do that essentially by Looting and pillaging her lands to demonstrate to everybody that the Romans can no longer defend their own lands
劫掠和洗劫罗马的土地来实现这一点，向所有人证明罗马人不再能够保卫他们自己的土地。
But above all he wants to annihilate her armies repeatedly in battle So that in the long run the Romans will be forced to sue for terms because this is what people do in antiquity. The Carthaginians have been fighting wars for centuries and centuries. It's never been a war of total annihilation. It's always been about forcing your enemy to sue for terms and then you arrive at a kind of compromise and everyone gets on with their lives. It's very Roman to assume that it's all or nothing. And this, I think, ultimately is what Hannibal doesn't understand. Perhaps he comes to the understanding of it over the course of his time in Italy. But at this point, he still thinks if he
但最重要的是，他想要在战斗中一次又一次地歼灭罗马军队，以便从长远来看，罗马人将被迫求和，因为古代人就是这么做的。迦太基人已经打了几个世纪的仗。这从来都不是一场彻底歼灭战。这总是关于迫使你的敌人求和，然后达成某种妥协，大家各自继续过自己的日子。认为这是一场非此即彼、你死我活的战争，是非常罗马式的想法。我认为，这最终正是汉尼拔所无法理解的。也许他在意大利的这段时间里逐渐明白了这一点。但在此时，他依然认为只要
can only force the ultimate climactic battle, then he will be able to get the Italians to cast off their loyalty to Rome, to come over to him and the Romans will be forced to sue for terms. And of course this requires him to tread very delicately on Italian toes. So that's one of the reasons why over the course of the winter he moves camp so he doesn't outstay his welcome. And it's why in the course of the summer of 218 he moves to a specifically Roman depot, a Roman entrepot full of stores and arms, which is called Cannae. And he captures this town, all the kind of the material, the weapons, the provender, the produce that are stored there are now Hannibal's. It enables him to cut across Roman supply lines. It prompts the local Italians to start wavering
他能强行引发最终的决战，他就能让意大利人抛弃对罗马的忠诚，倒戈向他，而罗马人将不得不求和。当然，这就需要他在处理意大利人的关系时小心翼翼。这也是为什么在整个冬天他要不断迁移营地，以免喧宾夺主。这也是为什么在公元前218年夏天的过程中，他转移到一个专门的罗马仓库，一个储满物资和武器的罗马转运站，名叫坎尼。他攻占了这座城镇，所有储存在那里的物资、武器、粮草、农产品现在都归汉尼拔所有。这使他能够切断罗马的补给线，促使当地的意大利人开始动摇
in their loyalty to Rome, which is everything that Hannibal wants. But also there is an additional advantage to it, which is that although Cannae stands on a slight ridge of hills, all around it, the land, and this is quite unusual for Italy, is completely flat. And because it's flat, this makes it perfect for cavalry. Cavalry is in many ways Hannibal's strongest arm and it's the Roman's
他们对罗马的忠诚，这正是汉尼拔所想要的一切。但除此之外还有一个额外的好处，那就是尽管坎尼坐落在一个微微隆起的小山脊上，但它周围的土地——这在意大利相当罕见——是完全平坦的。正因为它是平坦的，这就使其成为骑兵的绝佳场所。骑兵在许多方面是汉尼拔最强大的兵种，而它是罗马人
weakest arm. And so he's hoping, I think, to offer himself and his army as bait and Cannae is the hook. So he wants to lure them into another battle, another pitch battle, because basically he thinks he's unbeatable in pitch battles, do you think? I think he's backing himself, I think, you know, backing himself all the way. But he, you know, also he recognizes it's the only way he has any prospect of winning.
最薄弱的兵种。因此，我认为他希望将自己和他的军队作为诱饵，而坎尼就是鱼钩。所以他想把他们引诱到另一场战斗中，另一场阵地战中，因为基本上他认为自己在阵地战中是无敌的，你觉得呢？我认为他对自己很有信心，我想，你知道的，一路都对自己充满信心。但他，你知道的，也认识到这是他取胜的唯一可能途径。
I mean, he's right in that. He just has to beat them again and again and again and again. All right, so what about the Romans? Are they going to take this trap? Because if you remember from last time, Fabius Maximus, who had been serving as dictator, he'd been appointed for six months as sort of supreme magistrate, the man who makes the decisions in command of the Republic. He has been actually shying away from battle. I mean, his whole strategy has been wait and see, play the long game. Delaying. The Fabian strategy, right.
我的意思是，在这点上他是对的。他只需要一次又一次、一次又一次地击败他们。好吧，那么罗马人呢？他们会落入这个陷阱吗？因为如果你还记得上次的内容，费边·马克西姆斯（Fabius Maximus）曾担任独裁官，他被任命为六个月的最高长官，也就是掌握共和国指挥权的最高决策者。他实际上一直在回避战斗。我的意思是，他的整个战略就是等待观望，打持久战。拖延战术。
You said last time that a lot of the Romans don't like this. They think it's un-Roman, they're losing patience. So have they now definitively run out of patience by the time Hannibal sets up his base at Cannae? Well, I think we said in the last episode, Fabius' strategy, you know, it's not a long term one. It's all about giving the Republic time to recruit and to train and to arm enough men to provide an army that will be so overwhelming that Hannibal will be powerless to defeat it. And the emblem of the fact that the time of emergency is over and it's time to resume normal service and basically launch a war
费边战略，没错。你上次说过很多罗马人不高兴。他们认为这很不符合罗马作风，他们正在失去耐心。那么当汉尼拔在坎尼建立基地时，他们的耐心是否已经彻底耗尽了？嗯，我想我们在上一集里说过，费边的战略，你知道的，并不是长期的。这全是为了给共和国争取时间来招募、训练和武装足够多的人员，以提供一支强大到汉尼拔无力击败的军队。标志着紧急状态已经结束、是时候恢复正常服务并基本上对入侵者发动毁灭性战争的时刻是，当费边卸任独裁官时——他只当了六个月的独裁官，这是法律限制。举行了新的选举，选出了两位新执政官，这些执政官中，肯定有一位是带着“让我们击败汉尼拔并在战役中彻底消灭他”的竞选纲领当选的。这个家伙叫盖乌斯·特伦蒂乌斯·瓦罗（Gaius Terentius Varro）。
of destruction against the invader is the fact that when Fabius lays down his dictatorship, he's only dictator for six months, that's the legal restriction. There are new elections and two new consuls are elected and these consuls, certainly one of them has definitely been elected on a kind of let's defeat Hannibal and wipe him out in a battle ticket. And this is a guy called Gaius Terentius Varro. He is cast by both Polybius and Livy as being a bit like Flaminius, the guy who had lost the battle at Lake Trasimene. So he is cast as a kind of slightly magga figure. He's a novice homo, so he's someone from outside the mainstream, outside the conventional
无论是波利比乌斯还是李维，都把他塑造得有点像弗拉米尼乌斯，那个在特拉西梅诺湖战役中惨败的家伙。因此，他被塑造成了一种稍微有些民粹（MAGA）色彩的人物。他是一个新人（Novus homo），也就是体制外的人，出身于传统政治精英之外。根据李维的说法，他实际上是一个屠夫的儿子，我认为这不太可能，这大概反映了李维对那些出身低微却爬上位的人的势利心态。因为很显然瓦罗是一位非常能干的政治家。他在那一年竞选执政官的所有候选人名单中实际上名列前茅。这意味着随后当选为他同僚的那个人，一个叫卢基乌斯·埃米利乌斯·保卢斯（Lucius Aemilius Paulus）的人，尽管他出身于一个非常显赫的政治世系，是一个更传统的执政官，但他无法真正压制瓦罗，因为瓦罗确实有选举胜利的分量作为后盾。正因如此，波利比乌斯和李维才得以将瓦罗塑造成真正应对
political elites. And according to Livy, he's actually the son of a butcher, which I think is improbable, probably reflects Livy's snobbery about people who rise above their station. Because clearly Varro is a very able politician. He actually comes top of the whole roster of people who are campaigning to be consul that year. And it means that the guy who subsequently comes to be elected as his colleague, a guy called Lucius Imelius Paulus, although he's from a very distinguished political dynasty, so much more of a conventional consul, he can't really pull rank because Varro does have the kind of weight of electoral achievement behind him. And it's this that enables Polybius and Livy to cast Varro as the guy who's really responsible
整个战略负有责任的人。因此，波利比乌斯特别将他塑造成鲁莽、无能、固执己见的人。部分原因，我认为是因为很显然瓦罗在某种程度上确实如此——正如我们将要看到的那样。但这也是因为另一位执政官埃米利乌斯·保卢斯是波利比乌斯罗马赞助人的祖父。所以波利比乌斯不会去贬低保卢斯，而且波利比乌斯渴望免除保卢斯对这一战略的责任。李维也对此大肆渲染，将保卢斯塑造成一个非常明智、非常平衡、非常克制的人。
for the whole strategy. So Polybius in particular casts him as being rash, as being incompetent, as being headstrong. And in part, I think this is because clearly Varro was to a degree, I mean, as we will see. But it's also because Aemilius Paulus, the other consul, is the grandfather of Polybius' Roman patron. So Polybius isn't really going to diss Paulus and Polybius is keen to spare Paulus' responsibility for this strategy. And Livy also plays it up casting Paulus as a man who is very sensible, very balanced, very restrained.
但我认为这是无稽之谈。因此，就像特雷比亚战役一样，我认为两位执政官都绝对决心强行开战，因为如果不是这样，他们为什么要扩充军队？如果不是这样，他们为什么要向汉尼拔进军？他们为什么要违背罗马人思维方式中所有出于本能的东西？他们之所以坚定这一路线，是因为他们认为如果不消灭汉尼拔，那就真的会威胁到他们对意大利的控制。但同时他们也觉得这是一种极大的侮辱。罗马人不愿意被不尊重。而且他们也知道，如果他们击败了汉尼拔，
But I think that this is nonsense. So as with Trebia, I think that both consoles are absolutely set on forcing a battle because why else would they have raised their forces? Why else would they have marched against Hannibal? Why would they go against everything that is instinctual in the Roman cast of mind? And the reasons that they are set on this course is because they think if they don't wipe out Hannibal, then it absolutely does threaten their hold on Italy. But also they feel it as a massive insult. The Romans do not want to be disrespected. And also they know that if they defeat Hannibal,
那就结束了。汉尼拔不能——你知道的，罗马人可以挺过无数次的失败。汉尼拔不行。汉尼拔只要失败一次，战争就结束了。所以基于所有这些原因，你可以看出为什么他们认为费边战略已经完成了它的使命，但现在够了。我们加把劲吧。大干一场吧。他们有很长的时间来考虑这件事。我的意思是，几个月的时间已经过去了。他们有很长的时间来思考：好吧，这里有这个带着他所有骑兵等等的家伙，
then that's it. Hannibal can't, you know, the Romans can survive endless defeats. Hannibal can't. One defeat for Hannibal and the war is over. So I think all of those reasons, you can see why they think that the Fabian strategy served its time, but now enough. Let's crack on. Let's do this. And they've had a long time to think about it. I mean, months and months have passed. They've had a long time to think about, okay, here is this guy with all his cavalry and whatnot,
非洲人、高卢人等等。我们究竟要怎么击败他呢？汤姆，他们有没有想出一个新的有效战略？嗯，我们提到了索姆河战役，我知道对英国一战将军们有某种修正主义的看法，但我认为其中确实有一点，你知道的，传统的想法，即“那个没用，让我们再试一次，只是投入更多的人”。
the Africans, the Gauls and stuff. How are we actually going to beat him? And Tom, have they dreamed up a new effective strategy? Well, we mentioned the Battle of the Somme, and I know that there's kind of revisionist takes on British First World War generals, but I think there is a slight element of, you know, the conventional idea that, oh, that didn't work, let's try it again only with more men.
好的。这基本上就是正在发生的事情。而原因就在于，能够征召数量极其庞大的人员正是罗马共和国的立国之本。显然这是汉尼拔所做不到的。因此，他们的目标就是组建一支庞大到绝无战败可能的军队。所以他们所做的是，战场上已经有了四个军团。也就是说，特拉西梅诺湖战役后留在战场上的有两个军团，由未被消灭的执政官指挥，费边随后接管了这两个军团，然后他又征召了另外两个军团。所以那是四个军团。他们在公元前218年初被派往普利亚亚平宁山脉东侧监视汉尼拔。所以他们已经就位了。保卢斯和瓦罗这两位新执政官，随后着手每人征召两个新军团，总共又是四个军团，他们花了好几个月的执政官任期对这些军队进行操练、训练，为战斗做准备。现在这些军团比平常要大得多，因此每个军团由5000名步兵、300名骑兵组成。他们还从意大利同盟者中征集了同等数量的士兵。所以用心算一下，总数大约是80000名步兵，6000名骑兵。我的意思是，80000名步兵，
Right. Okay. That's basically what's happening. And the reason for that is because the ability to raise enormous numbers of men is what the Roman Republic is all about. And clearly it's something that Hannibal can't do. So the aim is to just raise an army that is so vast that there is no prospect of it possibly losing. So what they do is there are four legions already in the field. So there were the two legions that had been left in the field after late Trasimene under
这绝对是一个庞大的数字。无论按什么标准来看，更不用说古代世界的标准了。这大约是维拉公园球场（Villa Park）容量的两倍。我的天哪。这就是你的标准。这字面意思上几乎和《历史的rest》俱乐部成员一样多。是的。这有很多人。想象一下他们全都被消灭了。那会是你的标准。字面意思上几乎和《历史的rest》俱乐部成员一样多。是的，这有很多人。想象一下他们全都被消灭了。那会太可怕了。是的，太糟了。我的意思是，他们将构成多么强大的一支力量啊。认真点讲，这现在是一支远比汉尼拔所能指挥的任何军队都要庞大的力量，对吧？所以他们有
the command of the consul who hadn't been wiped out, which Fabius had then taken over and he had then recruited two further legions. So that's four legions. And they have been sent off at the beginning of 218 to shadow Hannibal on the eastern side of the Apennines in Apulia. So they are already in situ. Paulus and Varro, the two new Consuls, they then set about raising two new legions each, so another four in total, and they spend the early months of their consulship drilling them, training them, readying them for battle. Now these legions are much larger than normal, so each one consists of 5,000 infantry, 300 cavalry. They also recruit an equal number of men from the Italian allies. So mental maths, the total is about 80,000 infantry, 6,000 cavalry. I mean, 80,000 infantry, I
充分的理由认为，无论战术如何，我们的军队现在如此庞大，汉尼拔绝无可能击败我们。是的，整个城市现在都将投入战争的这种感觉因大约三分之一的元老院成员在军队中服役而得到加强。罗马精英们通过随时准备战斗来证明自己的地位，这种感觉在216年与汉尼拔作战的官兵名册中表现得非常非常明显。费边没有去，但他的前任骑兵长官梅内留斯·鲁福斯（Menesius Rufus）去了，他作为一名军事保民官服役，许多其他曾担任过执政官的人也是如此，因此他们拥有指挥经验。他们
mean, that is an enormous number of men. Yeah. By any standards, let alone the standards of the ancient world. That's about twice the size of Villa Park. Oh my word. That's your standard. That is literally almost as many people as there are members of the Restless History Club. Yeah. That's a lot of people. Imagine them all being wiped out. That would your standard. That is literally almost as many people as there are members of the Restless History Club. Yeah, that's a lot of people. Imagine them all being wiped out. That would be terrible. Yeah, awful. I mean, what a formidable force they would make. Let's be serious about it. This is now a force far bigger than anything Hannibal can command, right? So they have
都担任军事保民官，这基本上是作为指挥作战的两位执政官与庞大军团士兵之间的联络人。你知道，这不仅关乎兵力的庞大，还关乎指挥官们的丰富经验。这些军官在罗马历史上第一次宣誓效忠，这就是所谓的“军人宣誓”（sacramentum）。李维给我们提供了誓词的内容：绝不为了保全自己的性命而离开战场，也绝不为了除收回或寻找武器去打击敌人、或者拯救朋友之外的任何目的而放弃自己在阵线中的位置。这为日后几个世纪士兵加入军团时所宣誓言树立了模版。这一切都是为了培养共同目标的意识，即这确实是武装起来的罗马人民，在团结中联合起来，
good grounds for thinking, you know, no matter what the tactics, our army is now so enormous, there's no way Hannibal can beat us. Yeah. And this sense that the whole city is now going to war is enhanced by the fact that about a third of the Senate are serving in the army. And this sense that the Roman elites justify their status by their readiness to fight is very, very manifest in the roster of people going to war with Hannibal in 216. Fabius doesn't go but his erstwhile master of horse, Menesius Rufus, he goes, he's serving as a tribune, so are many others who have been consuls, so they have experience of command. They're
怀着一种由各个阶层、各个年龄段所共享的坚定决心。我认为这不仅出于心理原因，还因为这支军队的纯粹规模存在一个小问题，那就是它根本没有融合。我的意思是，这些军团中没有哪个真正和彼此并肩作战过。因此，瓦罗和保卢斯各自拥有他们自己的两个军团，然后你还有驻扎在坎尼以北的四个军团。这些军团都没有一起训练过，更不用说一起并肩作战了。其后果当然是，在某种程度上，军队的庞大本身也成了潜在弱点的来源，而不仅仅是力量的来源，因为它非常笨重，尾大不掉，它没有能力
all serving as tribunes who are essentially the kind of the link men between the two consuls who are in command and the mass of the legions. You know, it's not just about the vastness of the manpower, it's also about the seasoned experience of the commanding officers. And these officers, for the first time in Roman history, swear a formal oath of service, what's called a sacramentum. And Livy gives us the terms of it, never to leave the field in order to save their own skins nor to abandon their place in the line for any purpose other than to recover or fetch a weapon to strike an enemy or to save a friend. And this will establish a template for the oath that soldiers are swearing when they join the legions for centuries to come. It's all about fostering a sense of common purpose, that this really is the Roman people in arms, joined in a unity,
进行复杂的机动或类似的事情。它只能执行最基础的战术，而汉尼拔深知这一点。他的间谍会出动，他会进行计算和摸索。我认为这就是为什么在7月下旬会出现这样一个令人难以置信的场景：两位执政官终于与坎尼以北的其他四个军团汇合，然后他们向南推进，朝汉尼拔军队所在的坎尼进发。迦太基人就像温泉关看到波斯人逼近的斯巴达人一样，他们看到滚滚尘土腾空而起，接着是金属的反光，这支军队庞大得超出了他们最疯狂的想象。许多迦太基人感到相当紧张，这并不令人意外。
in a kind of sense of determination that is shared by every class of person, by every age group. And I think this matters not just for psychological reasons, but also because there is a slight problem with the sheer scale of the army which is that it's not at all integrated. I mean none of these legions have kind of really served with each other. So Varro and Powis, they each have their own two legions, then you've got the four legions that are on the sentry north of Cannae. None of these legions have trained or still less campaigned together. And the consequence of that, of course, is that in a sense, the very size of the army becomes a source of potential weakness as well as of strength because it's very ponderous, it's very muscle bound, it doesn't have the ability to
有一个被普鲁塔克记录下来的轶事，迦太基的一名军官，一个名叫吉斯科（Gisco）的人，对敌人的数量表示了惊讶。汉尼拔神情严肃地说：“是的，吉斯科，但你忽视了一个更令人惊讶的事实。”“那是什么？”吉斯科问。汉尼拔回答说：“为什么？在庞大的罗马军队中，竟然没有一个人叫吉斯科。”然后是一阵男子汉的爽朗笑话。我其实真的不明白他在说什么。他的重点是什么？他是说，好吧，他们有这么多人，但他们没有像你这样的人，吉斯科，吉斯科。我身边都是像你这样的人。我们有
do complicated maneuvers or anything like that. It can only do the most basic tactics and Hannibal knows this. His spies will be out there, he will be computing and working it out. And I think that that's why you have this incredible scene in late July when at last the two consuls have joined the other four legions north of Cannae and then they're advancing southwards towards Cannae where Hannibal's army is. And the Carthaginians, like the Spartans at Thermopylae seeing the Persians approach, they see great dust cloud kicking up and then the glint of metal and this army that is vast beyond their wildest imaginings. And it's not surprising that a lot of the Carthaginians feel quite nervous.
取胜的把握。我认为那则轶事在某种程度上概括了双方当时的心态，这是一种既紧张又自信、既犹豫不决又对即将到来的世界杯决赛充满热切期盼的混合心态。每个人都知道这是一场大战。我想这大概解释了为什么战斗没有立即打响。存在着一定程度的对视。你知道，就像两个重量级拳击手站在称重台上，然后互相侮辱之类的。所以一方会摆好战斗阵型，但另一方不会回应，然后另一方又会摆出阵型。他们以这种或那种方式进行机动。而波利比乌斯和李维在回顾这一幕时说：“哦，好吧，这是因为保卢斯有一天在指挥，他不想打仗，然后第二天轮到瓦罗，他急于打仗。”我认为这不是真的。我认为这反映了双方普遍存在的期待与紧张情绪的混合，他们都在让自己紧绷起来，但完全显而易见的是，一场战役势在必行，因为双方都绝无退路。毫无疑问，多米尼克，在公元前216年8月2日的
And there's an anecdote that's recordedians feel quite nervous and there's an anecdote that's recorded by Plutarch and it there's one of Hannibal's officers a guy named Gisco expressed himself astonished by the numbers of the enemy. Hannibal adopted a serious expression and said yes Gisco but you are overlooking an even more astonishing fact and what is that that? asked Gisco. Why? answered Hannibal. That in all that vast Roman army, there is no one called Gisco. And there is manly laughter. I actually genuinely don't get what he's talking about. What's his point? He's saying, okay, they have all these numbers, but they don't have anyone, you know, they don't have people of your caliber, Gisco. I am surrounded by people like you. We have
黎明，罗马人开始就位准备迎战，汉尼拔骑马到一个山脊上，看了一眼，向他的部下、他周围的参谋人员发出信号，说：“好吧，我们上吧。”罗马人清楚地意识到汉尼拔将接受他们的战役邀请。坎尼战役即将打响。所以我兴奋得快喘不过气来了。休息一下，回来了解接下来发生的事情。欢迎回到《历史的rest》。现在是公元前216年8月2日的黎明，在罗马指挥官瓦罗的帐篷外，一面红旗已经升起，汤姆，这是战斗即将打响的信号。请为我们描绘一下当时的场景吧。高级罗马军官已经开过简报，他们出去告诉士兵们的计划是什么。两位执政官，瓦罗和
the winning of this. And I think that that anecdote kind of sums up what seems to have been the mood probably on both sides, which is a kind of mixture of nervousness and confidence of kind of hesitancy, but also a kind of relish for the big showdown, the World Cup final that is approaching. Everyone knows this is the big one. And I think that probably explains why battle isn't joined immediately. There's a certain degree of eyeballing. You know, it's the two heavyweight champions kind of standing on the weights and, you know, insulting each other and that kind of thing. So one will draw up battle lines, but the other won't respond, then the other will do it. They're kind of maneuvering this way and that. And Polybius and Livy, when they look back at this, they say, oh, well, this
保卢斯，从他们的指挥部里走了出来，身上穿着执政官在战斗之日所穿的传统猩红斗篷。所以这不像是特雷比亚战役，当时汉尼拔突袭了罗马人，让他们没吃早饭就仓促应战。这一次罗马人在出发前都吃过了早饭，然后离开营地，能够在他们自己的将军所选择的地形上就位。现在，做关于战役的播客对我们来说一直是个难题。首先，在播客中描绘场景相当困难。其次，有时我们对军事调兵遣将的兴趣并不像我们应该有的那么浓厚。然而，对我来说这是一个例外，因为这是我从小就着迷的一场战役。我当时有一本书，作者是一位才华横溢的作家兼插画家，
is because Paulus is in command one day and he doesn't want to fight and then Barrow is the next day and he's eager to fight. I don't think that's true. I think it's reflective of the mixture of anticipation and nervousness that is characteristic on both sides they're kind of tensing themselves up but it's perfectly clear there is going to be a battle because there's no way that either side can back down and sure enough Dominic on the 2nd of August 216 Dawn sees the Romans taking up positions to offer battle and Hannibal rides out to a ridge, looks at it, gives the signal to his men, his general staff who were
名叫皮特·康纳利（Pete Connolly）。他写了一系列书，一本关于罗马人，一本关于希腊军队，然后他写了一本叫《汉尼拔与罗马的敌人》，我坐在这里时，这本书现在就摆在我手边，里面的插图和文字都是他自己创作的。他的看法是——我来设定一下场景。这里有一个非常平坦、毫无特征的平原，但有两个自然地貌决定了康纳利对战役发生地点的推断。其中第一个是一条非常蜿蜒的河流，名叫阿尔菲迪乌斯河（Alphidius），其河道随着时间推移已经发生了变化，但康纳利认为它距离坎尼所在的一条小山脊大约有一英里半。因此，你拥有这片位于群山与阿尔菲迪乌斯河之间的开阔地带，引用戈兹沃西（Goldsworthy）的话，
around him, says yeah let's go for this and it becomes clear to the Romans that Hannibal is going to accept their offer of battle. The Battle of Cannae is about to begin. So I am absolutely breathless with excitement. Come back after the break to find out what happens. Welcome back to The Rest is History. It is dawn on the 2nd of August 216 and outside the tent of the Roman commander Varro, a red flag has been hoisted, the signal Tom, that battle is about to begin. So paint the scene for us please. So the senior Roman officers have already met for their briefing and they've gone out to tell their men what the plan is. The two consuls, Pharaoh and
他赞同康纳利对这一点的看法：“这个位置的优势是显而易见的。罗马人能够将一个侧翼锚定在河流上，另一个侧翼锚定在坎尼附近的高地上，这使得迦太基骑兵不可能像在特雷比亚那样包抄他们的阵线。”我希望听众们能听懂。没错，这说得通。如果你认为罗马人开拔出来，在他们的左翼有一道山脊，而在他们的右翼有一条河，这意味着迦太基人更难
Paulus, have emerged from their headquarters and they are wearing the traditional scarlet cloak that a consul wears on a day of battle. So this is not the Trebia where Hannibal had bounced the Romans into fighting without having breakfast. This time the Romans have all breakfasted and then leaving camp, they've been able to take up position on ground of their own generals choosing. Now, it has always been a problem for us doing podcasts about battles. Firstly, that it's quite difficult to paint the scene on a podcast. Secondly, that sometimes we're not quite as interested in military dispositions as we should be. However, this for me is an exception because this is the one battle that I've been obsessed by since I was very young. And I had a book by brilliant writer and artist
用骑兵迂回包抄他们。是的，所以他们横跨地形展开，绝无可能被合围。还有一个进一步的好处，那就是他们不是迎着太阳，因为他们基本上大致朝南面对着敌人。这里有一个问题，那就是风卷起了尘土。那是意大利南部七月下旬的晚期，所以有很多尘土，风把尘土吹向他们的脸。但我认为瓦罗显然觉得这个位置的优势大于这一劣势。所以他的调兵遣将是：步兵居中，一如既往，罗马骑兵在他的右翼。也就是紧挨着阿尔菲迪乌斯河，一如既往地居中，罗马骑兵在他的右翼，也就是紧挨着阿尔菲迪乌斯河、紧挨着河流。然后同盟骑兵在
called Pete Connolly. And he wrote a series of what one on the Romans one on the Greek armies and then he wrote one called Hannibal and the enemies of Rome, which I still have it right next to me as I sit here and he did the illustrations for it as well as the writing the text. And his take was that I'll set the scene. There is this very flat featureless plane, but there are two natural features that determined where Connolly thinks the battle was fought. The first of these is a very winding river called the Alphidius, the course of which has changed over the course of time, but Connolly argues that it was about one and a half miles from a ridge of hills and Cannae sits on this ridge of hills. And so you have this stretch of open ground between the hills and the river Alphidius and to quote Goldsworthy,
左翼，紧挨着山脊。他们的角色纯粹是防御性的。你知道的，他们的数量和战斗力总是会逊于迦太基骑兵。他们的角色本质上是确保步兵阵线不会在侧翼遭到攻击。这非常非常重要，因为目标必须是步兵在罗马和意大利骑兵被赶跑之前击败迦太基步兵。瓦罗亲自指挥同盟骑兵，保卢斯率领罗马骑兵，这正是这一任务重要性的衡量标准。非常非常重要。但很显然，罗马人把希望寄托在步兵身上。所以我们大概应该描述一下，
who who buys into Connolly's take on this, the advantages of this position are obvious. The Romans were able to anchor one flank on the river and the other on the high ground near Cannae, making it impossible for the Carthaginian horse to envelop their line as they had at Trebia. So I hope that makes sense to the listeners. Right, that makes sense. If you think the Romans come out and on their left flank you have a ridge of hills and on their right flank you have a river and this means that it's harder for the Carthaginians
他们看起来是什么样的，他们是如何列阵的，他们是如何武装的，诸如此类的事情，因为这些不是军团，不是大多数人通过《角斗士》或其他影视作品所熟悉的那种罗马士兵。这是来自一个更早期时期的军队。基本上罗马步兵排成了四个Distinct（清晰可辨）的横队。所以第一阵线由轻装散兵组成，被称为“velites”（投枪兵），波利比乌斯明确指出这些是最年轻、最穷的人。他对罗马人如何在战斗中作战进行了非常详细的描述，而且非常残酷，他们经常穿着狼皮。你们拿着小长矛，穿着狼皮，在前方形成一道掩护屏障。
to outflank them with their cavalry. Yeah so they're stretched across the terrain and they can't possibly be encircled. So there's a further advantage which is that they're not staring into the sun because they're essentially facing kind of roughly southwards. There is one issue, which is that the wind is whipping up the dust. It's kind of late July in southern Italy, so there's quite a lot of dust and kind of blowing it into their faces. But I think Varro clearly feels that the advantage of the position outweighs that. So his dispositions, infantry in the middle, as ever, Roman cavalry on his right wing. So that's next to the Arphidias next to the middle, as ever, Roman cavalry on his right wing, so that's next to the Arphidius, next to the river. And then the allied cavalry is on the
用骑兵从侧翼包抄他们。是的，所以他们的防线延伸得很长，根本不可能被包围。因此还有一个优势，那就是他们没有迎着太阳，因为他们基本上是朝南的。这里有一个问题，那就是风把尘土刮了起来。当时是南意大利的七月下旬左右，所以有很多尘土正吹向他们的脸。但我认为瓦罗显然觉得这个地利优势超过了这劣势。因此他的排兵布阵是：步兵居中，一如既往，罗马骑兵在他的右翼。也就是在阿菲迪乌斯河旁边、中间的旁边，一如既往，罗马骑兵在他的右翼，所以那是在阿菲迪乌斯河旁边、紧邻河流。然后盟军骑兵在
left wing, which is next to the ridge of hills. And their role is purely defensive. You know, they're always going to be outnumbered and out fought by the Carthaginian horse. Their role is essentially to ensure that the line of infantry can't be attacked on the flanks. And this is really, really important because the goal has to be that the infantry defeats the Carthaginian infantry before the Roman and Italian cavalry can be chased off. And it's the measure of how important this is that Varro himself takes up command of the allied cavalry and Paulus leads the Roman cavalry. So very, very important. But obviously it's the infantry that the Romans are pinning their hopes on. And so we should probably just describe, you know, what they
左翼，靠近丘陵山脊。他们的角色纯粹是防御性的。你知道，他们的兵力和战斗力总是会被迦太基骑兵压制。他们的任务基本上是确保步兵防线不会遭到侧翼攻击。这真的非常非常重要，因为目标必须是让步兵在罗马和意大利骑兵被驱赶之前击败迦太基步兵。瓦罗亲自指挥盟军骑兵，保卢斯率领罗马骑兵，这充分说明了这一点的重要性。所以非常非常重要。但很明显，罗马人把希望寄托在步兵身上。所以我们大概应该描述一下他们的
look like, how they're lined up, how they're armed, that kind of thing, because these are not legions, not Roman soldiers of the kind that most people will be familiar with from gladiator or whatever. This is from a kind of earlier period. And essentially the Roman infantry is lined up in four distinct ranks. So the first line consists of very lightly armed skirmishers who are called velites and Polybius specifies that these are the youngest and the poorest. He gives a kind of very detailed account of how the Romans fought in battles and very gruevally, they would often wear wolf skin. You have your little spears and you have your wolf skin and you form a screen in front of
外表、阵型、装备之类的情况，因为这些不是军团，不是大多数人通过角斗士电影之类所熟悉的那种罗马士兵。这是早期时期的军队。基本上，罗马步兵排成四个清晰的纵队。所以第一线由装备轻便的散兵组成，被称为维利特斯（velites），波利比乌斯明确指出这些人是最年轻和最贫穷的。他对罗马人如何作战作了非常详细的描述，相当引人注目的是，他们经常身穿狼皮。你带着你的小矛和狼皮，在前方形成一道屏幕
the main block of the heavy infantry and they form three lines. So the first line is a group called Hastati. These are men in their late teens, early twenties. So they're young, they're full of vigor, but they're not as experienced as the next line of heavy infantry who are called the principes, so the chief men. These are guys who are in the prime of life. They're very fit, they're very strong, but they're also experienced. And then at the back, you have a line called the triarii, who are the veterans. Now how these heavy infantry armed is quite important
重步兵的主力，他们排成三列。第一列是一群被称为“哈斯塔蒂”（Hastati）的人。这些人处于十多岁到二十出头的年纪。他们很年轻，充满活力，但不如下一列被称为“普林西佩斯”（principes，即精锐战士）的重步兵经验丰富。这些人正处于人生的黄金时期。他们身体非常健硕、强壮，同时也很有经验。再往后，你有一列被称为“特里阿里”（triarii）的人，他们是老兵。现在，这些重步兵是如何武装的，这对于理解这场战役、对它有一个概念非常重要。
for understanding the battle to get a sense of this. All the heavy infantry have very heavy kind of large oblong shields which are held up with the left arm. So that's quite a strain on the arm over the course of a long day. They might have a kind of small oblong plate on their chest, the pectorale, or if they can afford it, chainmail. And they're armed with the Spanish stabbing sword. So this sword that opens up the guts of the person that you're fighting with, you know, if you, if you can get a clear stab at him. So the front two ranks, so that's the hastati and that the, um, the principes, they also have two javelins. And I'll just quote Goldsworthy
所有重步兵都配备了一种非常沉重的、用左臂举着的大型长方形盾牌。因此，在漫长的一天里，这对手臂来说是一种相当大的负担。他们的胸前可能有一种小型长方形胸甲，即“pectoralis”，或者如果他们买得起的话，会穿锁子甲。他们装备着西班牙刺剑。你知道，如果你能准确刺中的话，这把剑能剖开你正在战斗之人的内脏。所以前两列，也就是“哈斯塔蒂”和“普林西佩斯”，他们还配备了两支标枪。我在这里引用戈德斯沃西（Goldsworthy）的话，
on this because lots of people listening to this have a sense that these javelins, the pila, the legionaries throw them and they then have a kind of bendy head. It's meant to stick in the enemy's shield and that droops down. This is not true. I'll read Goldsworthy on how these javelins work. All of the weapons weight was concentrated behind the small tip, giving it great penetrative power. The length of the metal shank gave it the reach to punch through an enemy's shield and still go on to wound his body.
因为许多听这个节目的人都有一种印象，认为这些标枪——“皮拉”（pila，即重标枪），军团士兵投掷它们，然后它们有一种可弯曲的枪头。这据说是为了卡在敌人的盾牌上然后垂下来。这不是真的。我来读一下戈德斯沃西关于这些标枪是如何运作的：所有武器的重量都集中在小巧的尖端后面，使其具有极大的穿透力。金属杆的长度使其能够穿透敌人的盾牌，并继续伤及他的身体。
But even if it failed to do so and merely stuck in the shield, it was very difficult to pull free and might force the man to discard his weighed down shield and fight unprotected. So basically you don't need the head to bend. I mean it's a massive problem if you've got a great spear stuck in down shield and fight unprotected. So basically you don't need the head to bend. I mean, it's a massive problem if you've got a great spear stuck in your shield and you have to throw it away. And then the guy can come up with his gladius and slice your stomach open.
但即使它未能做到这一点而仅仅卡在盾牌上，也很难将其拔出，这可能会迫使此人丢下沉重的盾牌，在毫无保护的情况下战斗。所以基本上你不需要枪头弯曲。我的意思是，如果你的盾牌上插着一根大长矛然后不得不把它扔掉，那将是一个巨大的麻烦。然后敌人就可以拿着他的短剑（gladius）上来划开你的肚子。
So very bad news. The third rank, so this is the veterans, the triare. They have very long thrusting spears and they essentially are reserved. Should the first two ranks break, then they will form a kind of porcupine, a defensive screen bristling with spears. I'm aware that that might all sound rather complicated, but the aim of it is to enable fresh units constantly to be filtered up to the front.
所以这是个极坏的消息。第三列，也就是老兵，“特里阿里”。他们拥有非常长的突刺长矛，他们基本上是预备队。如果前两列溃败，他们就会形成一种豪猪般的防御屏障，上面布满了长矛。我知道这听起可能相当复杂，但这样做的目的是让新锐部队源源不断地被输送到前线。
So that if one line gets kind of annihilated or loses energy or whatever, then they can easily be replaced. And what gives the Roman line its flexibility is that there are kind of gaps built into the battle formations. The Roman lines are subdivided into units called maniples. And if people think of maybe a checkerboard or on a die a five, just lots and lots of those kind of fives that you get on on dice all in a row You have a manapal then you have a gap equivalent in length to the length of a manapal Then you have another manapal and then you have another row behind it But the manapal is behind it is filling in the gap But essentially it means that you can constantly thread people through the gaps and move people up to fill
这样一来，如果某一列被消灭、失去体力或发生什么情况，他们就能轻松得到替补。赋予罗马阵型灵活性的是，战斗阵型中预留了间隙。罗马的阵型被细分为被称为“马尼普尔”（maniples，即小队）的单位。如果人们联想到棋盘，或者骰子上的“五点”——就像骰子上一排排那种“五点”一样——你有一个小队，然后你有一个长度相当于一个小队长度的间隙，然后你又有另一个小队，然后你后面还有另一排，但后面的小队填补了这个间隙。这基本上意味着你可以不断地让人员穿过间隙，调动人员去填补……
Gaps can I the depth of the manapples, it's on a stupefying scale. So it's perhaps five or six men across. And then you think if you're standing in that line, then next to you, there's a gap that's equivalent to five or six men and then another five or six men and then another gap and then another five or six men and then another gap. And then standing behind you, you have maybe it's maybe 30 deep. So when you put all the manaples together, the battle line is maybe 70 ranks deep. So completely terrifying for the enemy. I mean to be up against the line a mile and a half long that is that deep. But there's also an additional advantage from the Roman point
小队的纵深规模大得惊人。横向大概是五到六个人。然后你想想，如果你站在那个队列里，你旁边是一个相当于五到六个人宽度的间隙，然后又是五到六个人，然后又是另一个间隙，然后又是五到六个人，然后又是另一个间隙。然后站在你身后，纵深可能有30人。所以当你把所有小队组合在一起时，战线纵深可能有70列。因此对敌人来说完全是极其恐怖的。我是说，面对一条长达一英里半且纵深如此之大的战线。但从罗马人的角度来看，
of view, which is bear in mind how raw many of the Roman recruits are. If you have lines that are that deep and you put your best most seasoned men in the front and the others at the rear, it's very difficult for raw nervous recruits who might want to run away to do that because you're surrounded by people, there's no way you can escape. And so essentially, it's a way of kind of getting over the fact that perhaps these aren't the best trained troops that you could possibly have. So from your description, it sounds like an extremely meticulously devised, well ordered, formidable military machine. But is there an argument that the sheer size and complexity of this system means that it's frankly a bit lumbering and a bit
还有一个额外的好处，那就是想想许多罗马新兵是多么缺乏经验。如果你有这么深的纵深，并且把最好、最有经验的人放在前面，而其他人放在后方，那么那些可能想要逃跑的紧张新兵就很难做到这一点，因为你被人群包围了，你根本无法逃脱。所以从根本上说，这是一种克服事实的方法，即这些可能不是你能拥有的训练最好的军队。那么从你的描述来看，这听起来像是一个极其精心设计、井然有序、令人生畏的军事机器。但有没有这样一种观点：这个系统庞大的规模和复杂性意味着它坦率地说有点笨拙，有点
over complicated and that Hannibal can actually exploit this? I think that you have seized on the weakness that Hannibal seizes on, Dominic. We're very similar people, to be fair. I think that's exactly the problem with it. The kind of the manipular system, which normally enables a Roman battle line to be very flexible. These maniples are so deep that actually it's quite difficult and that there's a risk of them crunching up against one another, in which case the flexibility would be completely lost.
过于复杂，以至于汉尼拔实际上可以利用这一点？我想你已经抓住了汉尼拔所利用的弱点，多米尼克。公平地说，我们是非常相似的人。我认为这正是问题所在。“马尼普尔”系统通常能使罗马战线非常灵活，但这些小队纵深太大了，以至于实际上相当困难，并且存在它们相互挤压碰撞的风险，在这种情况下，灵活性将完全丧失。
And I think Hannibal's aim is to try and apply pressure where it will force the sheer numbers of the Roman legions to come crunching into one another. And in which case its size rather than being an advantage then becomes a source of weakness. But it's a hugely difficult thing to pull off. So the Roman plan basically is just to kind of advance and steamroll of the enemy. Hannibal's dispositions are much more complicated. As usual, like the Romans have done, he stations his infantry in the center and his cavalry on the wings. He has Mahabal, who's in command of the Numidian light cavalry, on the right wing. So he is facing the allied cavalry commanded by Varro. On the left wing, so facing Paulus and the Roman
我认为汉尼拔的目标是试图在能够迫使罗马军团的庞大兵力相互挤压碰撞的地方施加压力。在这种情况下，它的规模不仅不是优势，反而成了弱点的根源。但这是一件极难完成的事情。所以罗马人的计划基本上就是推进并像蒸汽压路机一样碾压敌人。汉尼拔的部署要复杂得多。像往常一样，正如罗马人所做的那样，他将步兵部署在中央，骑兵部署在两翼。他在右翼部署了由马哈巴尔（Mahabal）指挥的努米底亚（Numidian）轻骑兵。因此他面对的是由瓦罗（Varro）指挥的盟军骑兵。在左翼——也就是面对保卢斯（Paulus）和罗马
cavalry, he's put the Spanish and Gallic heavy cavalry under the command of another very seasoned officer called inevitably Hasdrubal. So this isn't Hasdrubal the handsome, it's not Hasdrubal who's Hannibal's brother, it's another Hasdrubal. I just assume they're all called Hasdrubal, to be honest with you. Pretty much. And Hasdrubal is in command of about 7,000 men. So he is outnumbering the Roman cavalry under Paulus about three to one. So that is where the Carthaginians have the advantage. But obviously when it comes to infantry, that is a very different story because the Carthaginians there are massively outnumbered. However, fortunately
骑兵的地方——他把西班牙和高卢重骑兵置于另一个非常经验丰富的军官的指挥之下，不出所料，他叫哈斯德魯巴（Hasdrubal）。所以这不是“美男子”哈斯德鲁巴，不是汉尼拔的兄弟哈斯德鲁巴，而是另一个哈斯德鲁巴。说实话，我只是假设他们都叫哈斯德鲁巴。差不多吧。哈斯德鲁巴指挥着大约7,000人。因此他的兵力大约是保卢斯麾下罗马骑兵的三倍。这就是迦太基人占优势的地方。但很显然，当谈到步兵时，那就是完全不同的情况了，因为那里的迦太基人寡不敌众，处于绝对劣势。然而，幸运的是
for Hannibal, he has a plan. It's a very cunning plan. So what he does is he draws up his Spanish and Gallic heavy infantry in a continuous line facing the Romans, so stretching for almost a mile and a half. And compared to the Romans, this Carthaginian battle line is very, very slender. Hannibal stations himself and Mago, his younger brother, in the center of the line, and he then leads the center of the line outwards towards the Roman lines. So the effect is to create a kind of crescent. The line starts to bulge outwards towards the Roman center. Hannibal's aim in doing this is to ensure that the Roman effort
对汉尼拔来说，他有一个计划。这是一个非常狡猾的计划。所以他做的是，他排开他的西班牙和高卢重步兵，形成一条面对罗马人的连续战线，绵延近一英里半。与罗马人相比，这条迦太基战线非常非常薄。汉尼拔将自己和他的弟弟马戈（Mago）部署在战线中央，然后他带领战线中央向罗马军队的方向凸出。因此，其效果是创造了一种新月形的阵型。战线开始向罗马军队中央呈弓形向外凸出。汉尼拔这样做的目的是确保罗马人的进攻
will be kind of focused on the middle of the plain. And the reason that he does this is because he knows that this is how the legions fight, that their aim is always to push through the middle of their enemy's battle line. If they do that, then they will inevitably break through the Carthaginian line because it's so thin relative to the Romans. At the Trebia, the Romans had done that and Hannibal hadn't been able to stop them then from kind of marching off and doing what they wanted. But this time at Cannae, he has planned for this eventuality. So he is assuming that in the long run, the Roman line will break through the Spaniards and the Gauls and he has kept back
将集中在平原中间。他这样做的原因是因为他知道这就是军团的作战方式，他们的目标总是冲破敌人战线的中间。如果他们这样做，他们就不可避免地会突破迦太基战线，因为相对罗马人而言，这条线太薄了。在特雷比亚（Trebia），罗马人就是这么做的，而汉尼拔当时没能阻止他们行军并做他们想做的事。但这一次在坎尼（Cannae），他已经为这种可能性做好了计划。所以他假设从长远来看，罗马战线会突破西班牙人和高卢人，而他保留了
the Libyans who are like a kind of phalanx, great long spears and equipped with Roman arms and Roman armour so they actually look quite like the legionaries and these are Hannibal's best, most disciplined troops and he has stationed them behind the front line and at an angle to it. So that if you imagine the Romans break through the line of the Spaniards and Gauls, the Libyans are like a pair of pincers ready to close in. So the Romans will think that they've broken through, they go rushing forwards, the Libyans will close in and capture them on their flanks. I mean, that is a difficult maneuver to pull off. But obviously, if it does work, then potentially it's going to be very, very devastating in its effect.
利比亚人——他们就像一种方阵，手持长长的巨矛，装备着罗马人的武器和罗马人的盔甲，所以他们看起来实际上很像军团士兵，这些是汉尼拔最好、最有纪律的军队——他把他们部署在最前线的后面，并与前线保持一定角度。所以如果你想象罗马人突破了西班牙人和高卢人的防线，利比亚人就像一把准备合拢的双钳。因此罗马人会以为他们已经突破了防线并向前冲去，而利比亚人则会合拢并在他们的两翼将其包围。我的意思是，这是一个很难执行的战术。但很显然，如果它成功了，那么其效果可能会非常非常具有毁灭性。
So just to try and get our heads around this, what effectively he's doing, he's not exactly sacrificing his front line, but he's assuming that his front line will break, the Romans will break through, and his whole plan is that the Romans will break through and his whole plan is that the Romans will break through and then he's got these Libyans behind who will pour into the Roman flanks. Like the jaws of a mouth with sharp teeth. The downside is you don't want to be the people in the front line. Right. He's basically decided you're expendable.
所以，为了让我们理解这一点，他实际上在做的，并不是确切地牺牲他的前线，而是他假设他的前线会被突破，罗马人会冲过来，他的整个计划是罗马人会突破防线，然后他身后有这些利比亚人，他们将涌入罗马人的两翼。就像一张长着利齿的嘴巴的下巴。缺点是你不希望成为身处最前线的人。没错。他基本上认定你们是炮灰。
Yeah, but Hannibal has placed himself there. He's assuming that he will be, what, the Romans will just rush past him or that he will fall back. He's again backing himself, which is what he always does, that he will be, well, the Romans will just rush past him or that he will fall back. He's again backing himself, which is what he always does, that he will be able to inspire the men who are very, very loyal to him in the front row to fight as hard as possible. But it's accepted that at some point it will break. And then he has to hope that the Libyans will be able to play the role that he's assigned them.
是的，但汉尼拔把自己也置于那个位置。他假设他会……怎么说呢，罗马人会直接冲过他，或者他会后撤。他再次把赌注押在自己身上，这正是他一贯的做法，即他将能够——好吧，罗马人会直接冲过他，或者他会后撤。他再次把赌注押在自己身上，这正是他一贯的做法，即他将能够激励前排对极其忠诚于他的人们尽可能顽强地战斗。但大家默认在某个时刻防线会被突破。然后他必须寄希望于利比亚人能够扮演他分配给他们的角色。
It's a dangerous, complicated plan, but it is a plan. And of course, the other factor is that if the Libyans are able to seal the broken line and the front, you also have the cavalry in the rear who can then come up if they've swept away the Roman and Italian cavalry. They can then come galloping around and crash into the rear of the Roman army, and then you will have the whole army surrounded. And this has always been kind of Hannibal's dream. This is what he wants and he will have his battle of annihilation. But as I say, it's a complicated plan. So let's see what happens and see how it works out. So the battle lines are drawn up and I think there's always this sense of nervous anticipation
这是一个危险而复杂的计划，但它确实是一个计划。当然，另一个因素是，如果利比亚人能够封锁破裂的防线和前沿，你后方还有骑兵，如果他们消灭了罗马和意大利骑兵，他们就可以随后赶到。他们可以随后呼啸着冲向罗马军队的后方，然后你就会发现整支军队被包围了。这一直是汉尼拔的梦想。这就是他想要的，他将迎来他的歼灭战。但正如我所说，这是一个复杂的计划。所以让我们看看会发生什么，看看它是如何运作的。于是战线排开，我想在此之前总有一种紧张期待的感觉
before it happens. There's lots of maneuvering, there's blasting of trumpets and then you just wait and you can imagine, it's getting hotter, the sun is rising in the sky, the shields are starting to feel heavier on the arm, sweat around as you hold your spears or whatever. I mean, very, very nerve wracking. Because it's nerve wracking, ultimately the time comes where people think,
有很多排兵布阵，军号声震天，然后你只需等待，你可以想象，天气越来越热，太阳在天空中升起，手臂上的盾牌开始觉得越来越沉重，当你握着长矛或做其他动作时汗水直流。我的意思是，非常非常让人神经紧绷。因为神经紧绷，最终时刻来临，人们觉得：
oh, hang this, let's get on with it. And the people who begin are the skirmishers. The Carthaginians again are outnumbered, but they are much, much more proficient than the Velites, the Roman skirmishers in their wolf clothes and stuff. And in particular, the Balearic slingers, my favorite, are absolutely lethal. So they have a much longer range than
哦，管他呢，上吧！打起来再说。首先行动的是轻装散兵。迦太基人再次处于劣势，但他们比穿着狼皮等衣物的罗马轻装散兵“韦利特斯”（Velites）要熟练得多、厉害得多。特别是巴利阿里（Balearic）投石手，我最喜欢的兵种，绝对是致命的。他们的射程比
the Velites do with their little spears. They're very accurate. The slingshot is coming out, you know, you've got all this dust blowing up, very difficult to see the slingshot as it comes. If it hits you on the helmet, it is possible to kind of knock you out. And so understandably, the Roman infantry decide, well, we don't want this, you know, get rid of the Velites. The Velites withdraw. This is Daly's theory, I think he's right. They go right the way back behind the full line of the Roman heavy infantry. And this then means that the front line of the Roman heavy infantry are in a position to advance. This is what's been going on in the opening maneuvers of the battle. Meanwhile, you've got the cavalry and on the
拿着小标枪的“韦利特斯”要远得多。他们非常精准。投石索弹丸飞射出来，你知道，扬起漫天尘土，飞来的弹丸很难看清。如果它击中你的头盔，完全有可能把你打得昏迷不醒。因此，可以理解的是，罗马步兵决定：好吧，我们可不想受这个罪，除掉这些“韦利特斯”。“韦利特斯”撤退了。这是戴利（Daly）的理论，我认为他是对的。他们一直退到罗马重步兵完整阵型的正后方。这意味着罗马重步兵的前线处于可以推进的位置。这就是战役开局阶段所发生的事情。与此同时，你还有骑兵，在
banks of the Ophidius, the river, which is where Hastribals, Spanish and Gallic heavy cavalry are facing Paulus' Roman horse, is all kicking off. And the Carthaginians, even as the skirmishers are still doing their stuff with their javelins and their slingshot and stuff, the Carthaginian cavalry are herring towards the Romans. They just pile into Paulus and his men and there's a story in Plutarch that Paulus is wounded, that he has to dismount, that all his officers around him think, oh well he's doing it, we better do it, they dismount and then the whole Roman force dismounts and it may be that this is a kind of an attempt
奥菲迪乌斯河（Ophidius）河畔，哈斯德鲁巴的西班牙和高卢重骑兵正面对保卢斯的罗马骑兵，战斗全面爆发。迦太基骑兵甚至在散兵们还在用标枪和投石索大显身手的时候，就已经朝着罗马人狂奔而去了。他们径直冲向保卢斯及其部下，普鲁塔克（Plutarch）中有一个故事说保卢斯受伤了，他不得不下马，他身边的所有军官都想：好吧，既然他这么做了，我们最好也这样做，他们也下了马，接着整个罗马军队都下马了，这可能是
by the Romans to explain why it is that the Roman horse put up such a weak show. Anyway, they are absolutely swept away. They have not managed to put up a fight at all. Paulus is able to clamber his way into the main body of the infantry. So he is able to survive this route. But I mean, it's very poor on the part of the Roman horse and brilliant for Hasdrubal and his men who have swept the Roman flank clear. And Hasdrubal and his men who have swept the Roman flank clear and Hasdrubal does not do a Prince Rupert. So he doesn't go hering off after the Roman cavalry. He wheels round and he looks at the state of battle and what he decides to do we will come to in due course because meanwhile in the main field of battle where the two great blocks of infantry
罗马人的一种企图，用来解释为什么罗马骑兵的表现如此软弱。无论如何，他们被彻底扫荡了。他们根本没能组织起像样的抵抗。保卢斯勉强挤进了步兵的主力部队。因此他得以在这场溃败中幸存。但我的意思是，罗马骑兵的表现非常糟糕，而对哈斯德鲁巴及其部下来说则极其精彩，他们彻底清除了罗马人的侧翼。哈斯德鲁巴并没有效仿鲁珀特亲王（Prince Rupert）的做法——也就是说，他没有一路狂追罗马骑兵不放。他掉转马头，审视着战局，而他决定做什么，我们稍后就会讲到，因为与此同时，在两大步兵方阵
are facing one another, clash point is happening. So what's going on with the infantry? So the Roman young men, but probably the best, the most seasoned, the most proficient in fighting have been stationed in the front rank. They are smashing their weapons on their wooden shields, kind of terrifying counterpart to this great nodding crests that they have on their helmets. Their armor is brilliantly polished. And on the other side, you have the Spaniards and the Gauls.
相互对峙的主战场上，交锋点正在发生。那么步兵那边情况如何？罗马的年轻人，但很可能是最优秀、最有经验、作战最熟练的人，被部署在最前线。他们用武器猛击木质盾牌，与头盔上巨大而晃动的顶饰相呼应，发出一种可怕的声音。他们的盔甲被擦得锃亮。而在另一边，是西班牙人和高卢人。
They are holding their position. Remember the front of the bulge, very, very close to the Roman line. They're raising their own war cries, the Gallic war cries in particular notorious. They also have these trumpets, the carnics, terrifying din. And this is an age where people generally are not used to loud noise in the way that we are in the 21st century. So the din of the, you know, is overwhelming. And so it's not surprising that the moment that the skirmishes are out of the way, the Romans charge. They're thinking, you know, let's get this over and done with. The sooner this is done, the better for all concerned.
他们坚守阵地。记住那处凸出的前沿，距离罗马战线非常非常近。他们高喊着自己的战吼，尤其是高卢人的战吼远近闻名。他们还带着一种名为“卡尼克斯”（carnix）的长号，发出了可怕的噪音。这是一个人们通常不习惯我们在21世纪所习的那种噪音的时代。所以这种噪音简直震耳欲聋。因此，散兵一撤开，罗马人随即冲锋，也就不足为奇了。他们心想：快点结束吧，这事越早了结，对各方都越好。
So the Hestarte, they advance, the front ranks, probably the front two or three, because, you know, they don't want to start hitting their own men with javelins. They hurl them. The effect of this is less effective than normal because effectively they, you know, because of the bulge of the Carthaginian line, they can't actually reach most of the Carthaginian front line with their spears. And then they charge and the hope is that they will be able to break the enemy so that they just go running away and then the killing can start. But this doesn't happen. The Spaniards and Gauls hold their positions, partly because they're very seasoned veterans by this point, partly because Hannibal and Mago is there with them in the front rank, and partly because they just hate the Romans, and probably they trust in Hannibal that his strategy is going to work and that they're going to have their vengeance.
于是“哈斯塔蒂”向前推进，前排士兵——可能是前两三排，因为他们不想用标枪误伤自己人——投掷了标枪。这产生的效果不如平时那么显著，因为实际上，由于迦太基战线的凸出，他们的标枪实际上无法够到迦太基前线的大部分人。然后他们发起冲锋，希望能够击溃敌人，让他们四散逃命，接着就可以大开杀戒了。但这一切并没有发生。西班牙人和高卢人坚守阵地，一部分是因为他们此时已经是经验丰富的老兵，一部分是因为汉尼拔和马戈就在前排与他们同甘共苦，还一部分是因为他们对罗马人恨之入骨，并且可能他们坚信汉尼拔的战略会奏效，他们将报仇雪恨。
They understand also how important a role that they have, how important it is that they maintain their position for as long as they possibly can. And Daly in his book explains why. It was absolutely necessary for the peculiar crescent formation to be maintained so that the thin horns of the crescent, so that's the two flanks, would be kept out of the fighting for as long as possible. Because if the troops there broke early in the battle, the entire Carthaginian plan would collapse. So in other words, it's vital for Hannibal that the Roman forces are funneled into the center so that they can go into the mouth of these two Libyan jaws that are waiting to snap shut on them. It's a very kind of grinding clash. It's kind of man on man. And effectively the whole line
他们也明白自己扮演的角色有多么重要，尽可能长时间地维持阵地有多么重要。戴利在他的书中解释了其中的原因。绝对必须保持那种奇特的新月形阵型，以便让新月形的两角——也就是两个侧翼——尽可能长时间地置于战斗之外。因为如果那里的军队在战斗初期崩溃，整个迦太基的计划就会瓦解。换句话说，对汉尼拔而言至关重要的一点是，将罗马军队引入中央，这样他们就能自投罗网，落入那两个正等待合拢的利比亚“大颚”之中。这是一种非常漫长的残酷绞杀。这是一种人与人的搏杀，
is this kind of series of duels between Gauls and Spaniards against Romans. The Romans and the Spaniards are both armed with stabbing swords, so they're both aiming, you know, they're aiming at the abdomen. The Gauls have slashing swords, so they're aiming at the shoulders. And most of the wounds, because both sides have shields, are probably to parts of the body that aren't protected by either the shield or by armour. So that's heads, legs, sword arms. If you get too many wounds on your leg or your arm or to your head, then obviously you start to weaken. You might lose your balance, your ability to continue fighting, you might fall to the ground and the moment you fall to the ground that's it,
整个战线本质上就是高卢人和西班牙人对阵罗马人的一系列决斗。罗马人和西班牙人都装备着刺剑，所以他们的目标都是腹部。高卢人装备着砍剑，所以他们的目标是肩膀。由于双方都有盾牌，绝大多数伤口可能都出现在盾牌或盔甲没有保护到的身体部位。也就是头部、腿部、挥剑的手臂。如果你的腿、手臂或头部受了太多伤，那么很显然你开始虚弱了。你可能会失去平衡，失去继续战斗的能力，你可能会倒在地上，而一旦你倒在地上，那就完了，
you're dead, you know, there's going to be a blow to your head. Or just trampled underfoot. Trampled underfoot and of course the more bodies are trampled underfoot, the more they rise, the more slippery the ground becomes because blood is starting to spill out and you know moisten the dust that is everywhere and you have exhaustion as well because the sun is rising higher and higher in the sky. You've got the dust blowing in. And the estimate is that men can't really fight in this way for more than 15 minutes at a stretch. So the lines, you want to think of it, the lines are kind of engaging, then withdrawing, engaging, then withdrawing. Kind of almost the rhythm of a really brutal sporting
你死定了，你的头部会遭到致命一击。或者直接被踩在脚下。被踩在脚下，当然，被踩在脚下的尸体越多，他们堆积起来，地面就会变得越滑，因为鲜血开始喷涌而出，打湿了无处不在的尘土，而且你还要面对筋疲力尽，因为太阳在天空中越升越高。尘土飞扬。据估计，人在这种状态下，连续战斗的时间实在不能超过15分钟。所以这些战线，你可以这样理解，它们交锋，然后撤退，交锋，然后撤退。几乎就像一场极其残酷的体育
encounter, I guess. You know, very intense moments of engagement and then the players withdraw and kind of draw their breath and then back in again. And just physically relentless and demanding. But the advantage of the Roman manipular system is that people, you know, men who just become too tired or too wounded can be withdrawn and they can funnel more people forward. So there is this kind
比赛的节奏一样，我猜。非常激烈的交锋时刻，然后队员们撤退并喘口气，接着又投入战斗。这在体能上无情而苛刻。但罗马“马尼普尔”系统的优势在于，那些变得过于疲惫或受伤过重的人可以被撤下来，同时他们可以输送更多人向前。因此，有一种
of relentless sense of freshmen coming to the front line. And so it's unsurprising that as the fighting goes on, although the Gauls and Spaniards fight with the utmost ferocity and implacability, the Roman weight of numbers does start to tell and as the Roman front line grinds forward the crescent that the Gauls and the Spaniards have formed starts to flatten and then to buckle and to be pushed backwards and the Romans in the center give a great cheer, they consent victory, they push forwards, space opens up behind them as they do so, more troops come filling in to fill the gap, the order of the manaples starts to be lost, it's a great excited crush
源源不断的新生力量涌向最前线的无情感觉。因此，随着战斗的进行，尽管高卢人和西班牙人以最凶猛、最冷酷的顽强精神战斗，但罗马人的数量优势开始显现出来，随着罗马前线向前碾压，高卢人和西班牙人形成的新月阵型开始变平，接着开始凹陷并被迫向后退缩，处于中央的罗马人发出巨大的欢呼声，他们感知到胜利在望，他们向前推进，随着推进，他们身后的空间豁然开朗，更多部队涌来填补空隙，小队的秩序开始丧失，这是一场极度兴奋的挤压，
because everyone wants to share in the victory, cries of joy, of triumph kind of rippling through the entire Roman battle line. The feeling is absolutely that the battle is won, but of course Hannibal still has his two deadly cards to play. And as the Gauls and Spaniards retreat, space has opened up for the Libyans who are hitherto been held in reserve to crash into the flanks of the advancing Romans. And it happens exactly as Hannibal has planned. I mean, it couldn't go better because by now the Romans are so tightly packed
因为人人都想分享胜利的果实，喜悦和凯旋的欢呼声在整个罗马战线上此起彼伏。那种感觉绝对是胜券在握，但当然汉尼拔手里还有两张致命的王牌要打。随着高卢人和西班牙人的撤退，此前一直作为预备队被保留的利比亚人迎来了空间，他们得以猛烈撞击挺进中的罗马人的两翼。一切正如汉尼拔所计划的那样发生。我的意思是，事情不可能进展得更顺利了，因为此时的罗马人挤得如此紧密，
that they haven't got any opportunity to maneuver. And in fact, it's quite difficult for them even to raise their sword arms. And you just have this great scrum of men who are being slowly crushed together by the Libyan phalanxes to their left and to their right. And ahead of them, the Gauls and the Spaniards who had been retreating, you know, they get a second win, they sense that the balance of the battle has changed, they turn around, they block the Roman advance and the absolute horror for the Romans is that one minute they think they're winning, the battle is won, and then suddenly they find themselves surrounded on three sides by people who are not fleeing at all. And the Libyans are completely
以至于他们根本没有空间施展战术。事实上，他们甚至很难抬起挥剑的手臂。你只能看到一大群人被左侧和右侧的利比亚方阵慢慢挤压在一起。而在他们前方，原本一直在撤退的高卢和西班牙人重新恢复了体力，他们感觉到战局已经改变，转过身来，挡住了罗马人的前进道路。而对罗马人来说，绝对恐怖的是，前一分钟他们还以为自己要赢了，胜券在握，然后突然发现自己三面被根本没有逃跑的敌人包围了。而且利比亚人完全
fresh and more than that they actually look like Romans, so it must have come as a massive surprise for the Romans to suddenly find them crashing into them. So a horrible situation. And the Romans didn't anticipate this at all. I mean, you would think that practiced commanders would see the crescent shape and they would think, well, the one thing we don't want to happen is for our boys to be enveloped by the flanks of this crescent. And yet they've walked straight into it. Because they're trusting their weight of numbers, because that's how they fight, because they're not geniuses like Hannibal, because the men that they have are not seasoned, they can't kind of think on their feet, they're not practicedes like Hannibal because the men that they have are not seasoned, they can't kind of think on their feet, they're not practiced at maneuvering and that of course is the mark of
生力充沛，更不用说他们看起来就像罗马人，所以突然发现他们迎头撞击，对罗马人来说一定是个巨大的惊吓。真是一个可怕的局面。罗马人对此完全没有预料到。我的意思是，你本会认为经验丰富的指挥官会看到新月形的阵型，并认为：好吧，我们最不希望发生的事情就是我们的士兵被这个新月形的侧翼包围。然而他们却径直走进了这个陷阱。因为他们过分迷信自己的数量优势，因为那是他们的作战方式，因为他们不像汉尼拔那样是军事天才，因为他们手下的士兵并非经风雨见世面的老兵，他们不会随机应变，缺乏应变能力。当然，这正是
Hannibal's genius is that he you know he's exploiting all of that and he's like a judo thrower turning his enemy's strength into a weakness. And you said he had two cards to play, he's played one which was the Libyans. Now the second, of course, you mentioned it before, Hasdrubal and the heavy cavalry, as you said, they haven't gone shooting off. No. They now return to the fray, don't they? People may remember that they've swept away Paulus who has gone to join the main body of the infantry.
汉尼拔天才的印记所在，他正在利用这一切，他就像一个柔道高手，将敌人的力量转化为弱点。你刚才说他手里有两张牌要打，他已经打出了第一张，那就是利比亚人。现在是第二张，当然，你之前提到过，正如你所说，哈斯德鲁巴和重骑兵并没有一去不复返。没有。他们现在重返战场了，对吧？大家可能还记得，他们横扫了前去加入步兵主力的保卢斯。
The rest of the Roman cavalry have been swept away from the battlefield. So what Hasdrubal does is he then turns around the length of the Roman infantry to go to the other wing where the Numidians under Mahabal have been having a standoff with the Italians under Varro because the Numidians are light, they don't want to engage with the Italian cavalry. But now suddenly Hasdrubal and his heavy cavalry come sweeping up, the Italians are swept away again. Varro is swept away with them.
其余的罗马骑兵已经被赶出了战场。所以哈斯德鲁巴所做的是，他沿着罗马步兵的侧翼绕过去，前往另一翼。在那里，马哈巴尔率领的努米底亚骑兵正与瓦罗率领的意大利骑兵处于对峙状态，因为努米底亚骑兵是轻骑兵，不想与意大利骑兵正面交锋。但突然间，哈斯德鲁巴和他的重骑兵呼啸而至，意大利骑兵再次被横扫。瓦罗也随之被扫荡出局。
So he's gone from the scene of the battle. He survives, but he's, he's, he's now gone. This means that Hasdrupal and his heavy cavalry can now crash into the rear of the Roman infantry. And the likelihood is the infantry in the rear of the Roman battle line are not the seasoned veterans with their long spears who could have formed a phalanx and kept the cavalry away, but the velites, the skirmishers with their wolf skins, and there is nothing that
所以他已经离开了战场。他活了下来，但他已经不在局中了。这意味着哈斯德鲁巴和他的重骑兵现在可以猛烈撞击罗马步兵的后方。很有可能，处于罗马战线后方的步兵不是那些能够组成方阵并抵御骑兵的、手持长矛的久经沙场的精锐老兵，而是那些穿着狼皮的轻装散兵“韦利特斯”，面对重骑兵，他们
they can do against heavy cavalry. So in that description by Livy, you read of the battlefield the day after the battle, there was an account of men lying there whose tendons had been sliced and who can't move. And this I think is what Hasdrubal's cavalry are doing. As they gallop in, if they can't kill someone, they just slice the tendons and leave them there to exsanguinate the blood to spill out. And then they start crashing forwards and the press of Romans trying to withdraw pushes back in and the whole Roman army now is surrounded. You've got the Gauls and the Spaniards on the front, you've got the Libyans on the flanks, you've got Hasdrubal's cavalry in the rear. The process of annihilation is now set in train and it
无能为力。因此，在李维（Livy）的描述中，你读到了战役第二天战场的情景：有记载称，许多人躺在那里，他们的肌腱被割断，无法动弹。我想这就是哈斯德鲁巴的骑兵在做的事情。当他们纵马狂奔时，如果无法杀死某人，他们就只是割断其肌腱，然后将其留在那儿流血过多而亡。接着他们开始猛烈向前冲撞，试图撤退的罗马人相互挤压推挤，如今整支罗马军队彻底被包围了。正面是高卢人和西班牙人，两翼是利比亚人，后方是哈斯德鲁巴的骑兵。彻底歼灭的进程现在已经启动，这
takes Hannibal's men many hours and it must have been a hideous experience for everyone. I mean, completely exhausting even for for Annabelle's men. Their shields are heavy, their sword arms are starting to ache. They're drenched in sweat, lots of them are wounded. And I imagine that as the battle goes on, so the pauses between the bouts of combat go longer and longer. And for the Romans trapped inside, I mean, this just must have been.
花费了汉尼拔的人马数小时的时间，对所有人来说这一定是一段极其可怕的经历。我的意思是，即便对汉尼拔的士兵来说也完全是筋疲力尽。他们的盾牌很重，挥剑的手臂开始酸痛。他们浑身湿透了汗水，许多人受了伤。我可以想象，随着战斗的持续，战斗间隙的停顿越来越长。而对被困在里面的罗马人来说，我的意思是，这简直……
And we're talking about tens of thousands of men. Tens of thousands. So some of them managed to escape. You know, there were kind of gaps in the Carthaginian line they can get out. Some of the Italian allies surrender and that's fine. You know, Hannibal's policy is absolutely to accept their surrender. But the Romans though, you know, most of them stand their ground. A refusal to submit is the essence of what being a Roman is. It's the quality that's most admired in the Republic. And I think it's hard to overemphasize the horror of their fate, the physical crush, the panic, and the certainty of approaching death. Because if you're in the center of this kind of great crush of men, imagine, you know, you don't really know what's happening. And then the news comes to
我们谈论的是数以万计的人。数以万计。所以其中一些人设法逃脱了。你知道，迦太基防线有一些缺口，他们可以逃出去。一些意大利盟友投降了，这也没问题。你知道，汉尼拔的政策绝对是接受他们的投降。然而罗马人，你知道，他们大多数人坚守阵地。拒绝屈服是身为罗马人的核心本质。这是共和国最受赞誉的品质。我认为很难过分夸大他们命运的恐怖、肉体的挤压、恐慌以及对即将来临的死亡的确信。因为如果你身处这种巨大的人群挤压中央，想象一下，你其实并不知道发生了什么。然后消息传到
you about what's happened. You're stuck there waiting for the Carthaginian swords and spears to reach you. I mean, just hideous. People start to void their bowels to urinate with terror, to vomit. Piles of corpses are starting to rise. The sun is high in the sky, so they're starting to smell, it's drifting across the battlefield, death from the air, slingshot is starting to rain down again, you've still got this blinding dust and blood just everywhere drenching it. I mean it's like wading through a sea of blood and viscera and I think the trauma of it is most grotesquely and unsettlingly illustrated in that passage that you opened
你这里，告诉你发生了什么。你被困在那里，等待着迦太基人的刀剑和长矛向你袭来。我的意思是，简直太可怕了。人们开始大小便失禁、因恐惧而小便、呕吐。尸体堆开始堆积起来。太阳高悬在空中，所以尸体开始发臭，气味在战场上弥漫，从空中飘来死亡的气息，投石索弹丸再次如雨般落下，你仍然被这刺眼的尘土和无处不在、浸透一切的鲜血所包围。我的意思是，这就像在血海和内脏中蹚行，我认为这种创伤在开篇时你向大家朗读的那个段落中得到了最光怪陆离、令人不安的诠释。
this episode with. People may remember that Livy reports how the day after the Carthaginians inspect the battlefield and they find among the Roman dead some with their heads buried in the ground. I mean, I can't believe that's true, but if it is, then it's either kind of suicide or an attempt to hide from the horrors of the battle and the fact that Livy records it, I mean it must have been a story that was current at the time and therefore surely reflective of the scale of the horror and by the end of the day, upwards of you know, I mean tens of thousands of Romans are dead. Yeah, just looking at the estimates between 50 and 70,000 men probably were killed.
大家可能还记得，李维记载了第二天迦太基人视察战场时，在罗马阵亡者中发现了一些将头埋在泥土里的人。我的意思是，我简直不敢相信这是真的，但如果它是真的，那要么是一种自杀，要么是试图躲避战场的恐怖，而李维既然把它记录下来，那一定是一个当时流传的故事，因此肯定反映了恐怖的规模，到了当天结束时，高达……我的意思是，成千上万的罗马人阵亡了。是的，只要看一下估计数字，大约有5万到7万人被杀。
I mean, just absolutely massacred where they stood. And, you know, for Hannibal, this must be a victory beyond his wildest dreams. I mean, just a staggering success, a vindication of his tactics, of his approach. He has absolutely annihilated this Roman army and brought the Romans to their lowest ebb. I mean, I think you could say it's the most astonishing, the most remarkable victory that any general had ever won in history. And that is why it continues to be studied and admired by military strategists to this day. And you can't say that of any other ancient battle. It has a kind of perfection, a terrifying perfection about it. And yet he hasn't won the war because the question now is what will the Romans do?
我的意思是，就在他们站立的地方被彻底大屠杀。而且，对汉尼拔而言，这一定是一场超乎他最疯狂梦想的胜利。我的意思是，这是一场令人震撼的巨大成功，是对他的战术和方法的证明。他彻底歼灭了这支罗马军队，将罗马人逼入了最低谷。我的意思是，我认为你可以说这是历史上任何将领赢得的最惊人、最非凡的胜利。这就是为什么至今它仍受到军事战略家的研究和赞赏。你不能对任何其他古代战役这样说。它有一种完美性，一种可怕的完美性。然而他并没有赢得战争，因为现在的问题是罗马人会怎么做？
Will they sue for peace? You know, where does he go from here? Does he march on Rome? Does he try to destroy the Republic or have the Romans got one more comeback left in them, Tom? Do you know, Dominic, we are going to leave that question as a cliffhanger. We are going to end our series on the rise of Hannibal at this point. Hannibal has attained the absolute pinnacle of everything he could have dreamed of.
他们会求和吗？你知道，他从这里将走向何方？他会进军罗马吗？他会试图摧毁共和国吗？还是罗马人手里还有最后一次绝地反击的机会，汤姆？你知道吗，多米尼克，我们将把这个问题当作一个悬念留下。我们将在此时结束我们关于汉尼拔崛起的系列节目。汉尼拔已经达到了他所能梦想的一切的绝对巅峰。
But as you say, there is still the fact that Rome is not yet defeated. Should Hannibal march on Rome? What's going to happen? And we will hopefully answer those questions with a third series, which will take the story forwards. And that series as well will end on a terrible note. We love a terrible note on the rest of history. We also like to torment and tantalise our listeners by leaving them hanging at the end of series.
但正如你所说，罗马尚未被击败的事实依然存在。汉尼拔应该进军罗马吗？接下来会发生什么？我们希望在第三季中回答这些问题，第三季将把故事推进下去。那一季同样会以一个可怕的结局收场。我们“历史余烬”（The Rest Is History）节目非常喜欢可怕的结局。我们也喜欢通过在每季结尾把听众吊胃口、悬吊起来，来折磨和撩拨他们。
And that's what we've done. We've had season one, we've had season two, season three will be coming. Brilliant. So next week we will be back with something very different. We'll still be in Italy, but we will be in the golden age of Renaissance Florence for the story of the Medici. But Tom, thank you so much for that. A blood curdling tour de force, I think it's fair to say.
这就是我们所做的。我们有了第一季，我们有了第二季，第三季即将到来。太棒了。所以下周我们将带着完全不同的内容回归。我们仍将身处意大利，但我们将进入文艺复兴时期佛罗伦萨的黄金时代，讲述美第奇家族的故事。但汤姆，非常感谢你带来这些。我认为可以公平地说，这是一次令人毛骨悚然的巅峰之作。
And never has there been so much dust in a Restless History podcast. Dust and blood. Dust and blood. We love it. On that bombshell. Thank you very much and goodbye everybody. Bye bye. Hi everybody, you're still here right at the end of the episode. I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to
在《历史余烬》播客中，从来没有过这么多的尘土。尘土与鲜血。尘土与鲜血。我们太喜欢了。伴随着这枚重磅炸弹。非常感谢大家，再见！再见！嗨，大家，你们竟然还在这一集的最后。我对你们的执着印象深刻。但听着，我有一个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些单集里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗，我希望这个播客的听众，我希望他们听的是
an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that there is of course, only one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on The Rest Is History. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on The Rest Is History and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to Goalhanger.com right now. And that is Goal,
关于我的品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你有过这种想法，当然只有一个方法可以知道那会是什么样。你可以打断广告的进程。你可以成为下一个汇丰尊贵理财（HSBC Premier）或在《历史余烬》上投放广告的许多其他了不起的公司之一。你可以通过在《历史余烬》以及“挂球网”（Goalhanger Network）的其他节目上投放广告，将你的品牌展示给数百万志同道合的听众。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是“挂球网”。挂球网就是打造这个节目的公司。如果你正打算提升你的品牌价值，挂球网非常希望能听到你的声音。你可以现在就访问 Goalhanger.com 注册你的兴趣，或者你公司的兴趣。网址是 Goal，
G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
G-O-A-L，Hangar，H-A-N-G-E-R，点com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。